ein schelm wer hier an kunst denkt ganz
fahrer künstler wetz mit assistentin
martin jost auf pirsch im sammel hof
sursee
[Musik]
abtauchen und ungefähr einen witz findet
hier ersatzteile für seine kunstwerke
für witz gelten die gesetze des wahren
kreislaufs auch in der kunstwelt
installation nämlich pragmatismus zeigt
jetzt nicht nur als künstler sondern
auch als leiter des kunst- und
kulturzentrums im landessender
beromünster kurz kkl b
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in der großen installation ziele war
glücklich einem panoptikum von über 100
episoden aus der familiengeschichte von
witz
[Applaus]
mit seiner kunst will er dem publikum
primär ein sinnliches erlebnis bieten
wir sind untersucht vor der performance
besucher im raum wie bt dorf arcen wii
sports media
jetzt werden wir unsere technologien
bayerisch der ins team er ist oft noch
mit wohnküche mehr und lag schon zur
anga warmluft damit wie über das neue
verriet es gibt auch in die tücken
gewahrt
die drei delegationsleiter diese
einstellung stand nicht von ungefähr
damals also mit dem großer meister droht
das linienschiff dass ich so was nie
interessiert habe hingegen kreuz machen
hätte interessiert das amt beworben ist
schon funktioniert und die swisscom
das ist völlig irre wendigkeit dass ich
so was sie sehen
[Musik]
wir werden zeuge einer weltpremiere der
ersten performance mit dem publikum
zwei neue artists in residence werden
noch dazustoßen
im zweiten teil dieses kunst happenings
dass bereits jetzt über wochen hinaus
ausgebucht ist
es ist für mich immer wichtig dass es
ein sport und dann wieder verschwinden
es muss das spielte bevor man schön dass
es noch dinge wieder weg ist
die spannung steigt die performance
steuert auf ihren höhepunkt zu
zeit für den auftritt der neuen
mitarbeitenden frau ist und herr hirsch
es ist ihr erster einsatz in der kunst
wäre doch mit etwas überwinde und
klappt's
[Musik]
auch ein diesel von kunst und karotten
nichts übrig lassen
erst ihr beitrag vollendet diese
performance